with over two dozen different marvel
movies and more than a few marvel
television shows
we've seen some incredible comic
book-based performances from some of
hollywood's very best actors
not all of those actors are still with
us but thankfully they've left behind a
long and impressive body of work
even beyond their marvel roles here are
marvel actors you may not know
passed away powers booth
if you don't recognize power's booth
from his brief appearance in the
avengers
or his run on marvel's agents of shield
you probably know him as cult leader jim
jones in guyana tragedy
a role that won him an emmy you may also
know him as the conniving brothel owner
cy toliver on hbo's deadwood or as 24's
vice president noah daniels
marvel fans however will always see
booth as gideon malik the shadowy world
leader that was first seen in the
avengers where he encouraged nick fury
to nuke new york city in order to stop
loki's alien army malek later returned
for marvel's agents of shield
as season three's big bad and the head
of hydra
you have less than 15 minutes to breach
their barricades and regain control of
that chamber
sir soldier malik isn't the only comic
book character that booth played either
he voiced guerrilla grodd and red
tornado in justice league unlimited
played lex luthor in the animated
feature superman brainiac attacks
and appeared in both sin city movies as
senator rourke
sadly booth passed away in may 2017.
on-screen villainy will never be the
same
roy scheider when a group of thugs show
up at the castle family reunion looking
to exact revenge in 2004 as the punisher
roy scheider's frank castle senior is
there to stop them
in their tracks
not that you'd expect anything less from
the man who faced down jaws not once
but twice and live to tell the story as
police chief martin brody
scheider is one of the three men who
take to the seas in order to stop the
tourist eating great white
reportedly scheider even improvised
brody's most famous line
[Music]
you're gonna need a bigger boat he left
behind an impressive resume beyond jaws
though he received an academy award
nomination for playing grizzled
detective cloudy russo in the french
connection and another for his role in
all that jazz
scheider passed away in 2008
gary shandling in iron man 2
gary shandling's senator stern tries to
discredit iron man
and transfer tony stark's tech for the
united states government but the extent
of his villainy becomes even more
established in captain america the
winter soldier
it's one of the most memorable parts of
marvel movie history but it's barely a
footnote in shandling's long and
accomplished career
chandling started his career as a writer
for 70 sitcoms
but decided to pursue stand-up comedy
appearances on the tonight show landed
channeling a gig as one of johnny
carson's go-to guest hosts
and eventually led to the subversive
fourth wall breaking sitcom it's gary
shandling show
later chandling funneled his tonight
show experience into the larry sanders
show
an hbo series about a late night talk
show over the course of its six season
run
the larry sanders show amassed a
whopping 56
emmy nominations helped make jeffrey
tambor rip torn and janine garofalo into
household names
and cemented its place as one of the
greatest television shows ever made
unfortunately chandling passed away in
2016.
bill paxton fan favorite character actor
bill paxton
added a helpful dose of star power to
marvel's agents of shield when he
brought the cyborg assassin
john garrett to life on screen for the
very first time in 2014.
why do i hear gunfire you hear the dying
breath of an old world general
but a new world is coming i've tasted it
on my tongue
as garrett paxton lured straight-laced
shield agent grant ward to the dark
side uncovered the secret behind phil
coulson's mysterious resurrection
and ultimately ended up on the wrong
side of coulson's disintegration gun
unfortunately paxton who made his name
as a scene-stealing presence in classic
movies like aliens
terminator edge of tomorrow true lies
and many many others
passed away just a few years later due
to complications resulting from heart
surgery
neil fingleton a british athlete turned
actor who stood
at a record setting seven feet seven
inches tall
neil fingleton was officially the
tallest man in britain he played college
basketball at the university of north
carolina
and college of the holy cross
represented britain in the world
university games and later played
professionally
in boston italy spain and greece however
fingleton's sports career came to an
abrupt end in 2007
when an injury finished his time on the
court he turned to acting
where his massive size landed him all
kinds of unique roles
in doctor who fingleton appeared
opposite peter capaldi
as the would-be conqueror fisher king he
also played game of thrones resident
giant
mag the mighty on the marvel side
fingleton actually played two roles
fingelton helped bring ultron to life
working as both a stunned performer
and motion capture artist on avengers
age of ultron
he also played a russian bodyguard in
x-men first class
he died of heart failure in february of
2017.
cliff robertson compared to the rest of
the cast in spider-man
cliff robertson's uncle ben might not
have the most screen time
but it's his teachings that ultimately
inspire peter parker to become
spider-man
remember with great power comes great
responsibility
much like ben robertson was a real life
hero
while he stole hearts as a young john f
kennedy in pt 109
and won an oscar for the lead role in
charlie he's
probably best known for taking a stand
against hollywood corruption
in 1977 robertson reported that columbia
pictures head david begelman had forged
his name on a ten thousand dollar check
as part of a massive embezzling scheme
in the aftermath
begelman lost his job and hollywood
bigwigs refused to give robertson more
parts
robertson never fully embraced the show
business machine and he wasn't sorry for
his actions shining a light on hollywood
corruption
robertson passed away in 2011. harry
dean stanton
if you don't know harry dean stanton's
name you certainly know his face
in the 60s and 70s he slowly emerged as
one of hollywood's most reliable
character actors
thanks to memorable bit parts in films
and television shows like cool hand luke
gunsmoke and the godfather part 2.
stanton's popularity eventually led to
bigger supporting roles
including parts in alien escape from new
york and the green mile
in 1984 he took the lead in the
critically acclaimed paris texas
and the same year he co-starred his bud
in the cult classic sci-fi romp
repo man he's also notable for playing a
recurring part in twin peaks to return
his second to last project before his
september 2017
passing in between his pack schedule
stanton found time to sneak into the
marvel cinematic universe
with a scene stealing performance as a
wise janitor in the avengers
i'm out of space an alien
well then son you've got a condition
eugenie eugene lazarus in the marvel
cinematic universe
anton vanco was a longtime stark
industries employee who helped develop
the ark reactor before being found
guilty of espionage
and shipped back to russia after a
lengthy stint in siberia ivanko returned
to civilization to raise his son
turning ivan vonko against the starks
and creating iron man 2's main villain
whiplash thankfully the actor who played
banco
euv guinea eugene lazarus wasn't quite
so twisted in real life
a russian native lazariff was a
well-known and accomplished actor in his
motherland
where he was honored with the people's
artist of russia title the most
prestigious government award
a russian performer can attain on his
move to the united states
lazarus kept right on acting appearing
in films and tv shows like the pink
panther 2
24 alias the west wing lord of war and
many others
he didn't keep all of that experience to
himself either
between roles lazarus taught acting at
the university of southern california
sadly he died of a heart attack in 2016.
michael clark duncan when you're casting
someone like new york crime boss
wilson fisk better known to superhero
fans as kingpin
you need someone who's got a huge
presence michael clark duncan didn't
just look the part with his six foot 300
pound frame
he also had charisma to spare the
actor's stature helped him land the gig
as the big bad in 2003's daredevil
have you seen the papers today
somebody's been talking
[Music]
somebody always does duncan a superhero
fan since childhood was very
enthusiastic about playing fisk
he re-read frank miller's comic book run
from front to back before filming
daredevil
and returned to voice the character in
spider-man the new animated series
still the kingpin was just one of many
memorable parts duncan played over the
years
duncan appeared in films like armageddon
the whole nine yards
sin city and others usually playing
criminals or other heavies
but his star making turn came in 1999
when he joined the cast of frank
darabont's the green mile
duncan landed the role as the imposing
but gentle inmate john coffey
and was rewarded for his efforts with a
handful of award nominations
including one for best supporting actor
duncan passed away from a heart attack
in september 2012. bill bixby
visit any reasonably sized comic book
convention and you'll find that lou
ferrigno
the six foot five bodybuilder who played
marvel's jade giant on the 1977
incredible hulk television show
is live well and still signing
autographs for adoring fans
unfortunately his on-screen alter ego
bill bixby
is no longer with us bixby will always
be best known for his portrayal of david
bruce banner
the heroic scientist who traveled the
country in search of a cure for his
condition mr mcgee
don't make me angry you wouldn't like me
when i'm angry
even without the marvel bonafides he'd
be well remembered
in 1971 he was nominated for a best
actor emmy for his ongoing role in the
courtship of eddie's father
and followed that up in 1976 with two
more emmy nods
he was an accomplished director helming
30 episodes of blossom
as well as other television shows
bixby's showmanship extended off-screen
too he performed all of his own tricks
while starring in nbc's the magician
sadly bixby passed away in 1993 after a
two-year battle with cancer